what was it like the very first time
that you got to put the baby bump on I
was so happy to wear it I think I mean I
think I've spent six seasons playing
this character in a very specific way
and sure she's had a lot of changes over
the years but this is the most
significant certainly physical change
and it gave me something new to play
with yeah she got to ditch the corset
[Music]
you're so close
Oh a month actually feels like a long
time do you think it's a boy or a girl
we'll find out soon enough
it's funny cuz you know she's not
pregnant but then you're on set with her
and you find yourself going with or you
okay watch that step and you know it's
fictional was there a little extra
special treatment
everyone was so normally nice okay so
Laurie your first reaction when you got
to see Erin wearing the bug oh my
goodness I was so excited she looks so
beautiful and even though you know it's
fake you have that emotional reaction of
like oh wow you know it's just you got a
little emotion yeah yeah well I get
emotional about our show I get emotional
about everything the fire I get I cry
all the time one day very soon when
you're holding your baby the only thing
you will be overwhelmed how much
childbirth are we gonna meet this baby
after we see the Christmas movie
yes we will have met the baby yes baby
Thornton arrives giving birth on camera
or or the act of labor on camera as an
actress what is that like oh it's a lot
of turning to Laurie and Pascal and
saying yes yes and I wait I my girls are
19 and 20 Pascal has younger children so
I was like Pascal I'd watched a lot of
show a baby story I've seen a lot of
births take place on television and so I
felt like I I knew sort of what what I
needed to look like so like a lot of
uncomfortable breathing there's a lot of
breathing okay been moaning does this it
all give you a little baby fever in real
life experiencing it on when calls the
heart you have baby fever for sure she
sends me pictures of the babies that
play her babies and I love those I know
okay but everybody just relax
so no babies in real life perhaps not
very good I will love you being right
down so you just mentioned it's gonna be
two babies it's twins
why always have twins you so it's one
baby but you always have twins playing
the Braga's with everyone full you know
yeah yeah yeah so what was the
experience like the first time you got
to meet these children that are playing
your on-screen child I loved meeting
Elizabeth's Big B for the first time
babies in this case and I went to their
trailer and got to say hello anyway
these babies look like her incredibly
expressive have there been any funny
moments I know working with babies
anything can happen
they're serious even baby just for wait
she's up and fully close to my mouth
like dicks
baby's hand in my mouth and I just left
a pair so baby was ready okay this is in
a month or so all this attention will be
on your baby something to look forward
to hopefully three words oh I'm up the
one calls the heart Christmas movie
magical uplifting heartfelt
[Music]